j'ai deux questions j'en ai une pour
Monsieur Gali et une pour Monsieur Hugé
alors Monsieur Gali vous avez
certainement constaté que qu'il y a
depuis près d'un an un déport des mules
vers les Antilles depuis la mise en
place des contrôles à 100 % à l'aéroport
Félix sboué en Guyane il y a fort à
parier que les trafiquants sont à la
recherche de nouvelles routes ma
question est simple existe-t-il
aujourd'hui un travail en collaboration
entre les services aux Antilles et la
Guyane puisque les douaniers guyanais
pourraient le cas échéant indiquer à
leurs collègues des Antilles les mules
potentiels et Monsieur Hugé la
multiplication de saisies de stupéfiants
et de démantellement de réseaux tant en
Guadeloupe et Martinique démontre que
vos
territoires comme le mien d'ailleurs se
trouve au milieu d'un trafic
international or dans un rapport
d'information publié début juillet mes
collègues sénateurs déploraient la
faiblesse des moyens nautiques et
aériens alloués à la lutte contre le
trafic de stupéfiants les forces de
l'ordre rencontré ont expliqué qu'elle
ne dispose pas de moyens d'assurer la
pleine et totale surveillance
périmétrique de l'île et n'avoir
toujours pas pu installer de radar au
sein du port maritime de fort-de-fance
pour contrôler les cargaisons
pouvez-vous me dire si les choses ont
évolué favorablement depuis ce rapport
pour avoir écouté les auditions des m
puisque moi j'ai été aussi maire de
Cayen pendant 10 ans euh je je pose la
question qu'est-ce que vous pensez de
l'opportunité de la création d'une
commission ad hoc composée de la PN la
PM la
la l'état bien sûr
euh oh là là
j'aiécrit de ouai voilà douan douan
surtout les maires les maires parce que
les maires se sentent souvent exclus des
résultat du dispositif et bon les maires
ont quand même quelque chose à faire
aussi au niveau de des dealur au niveau
des des B des trafiquants qui sont dans
leur commune et donc je me posais la
question et que c'était pas au porteur
de créer une commission où tout le monde
pourrait se retrouver autour d'une table
hormis le CLSPD ou la collaboration
entre la PN et la PN pour pouvoir
justement éradiquer ce trafic parce que
c'est vraiment un fléau dans nos dans
nos villes je vais euh répondre à à
cette question centrale euh justement
euh sur c'est dire la coproduction de
sécurité et bien c'est le projet du
contrat territorial de sécurité de
prévention à laquelle la collectivité
territoriale de Martinique mais
également madame la sénatrice concon et
tous les maires nous avons eu en début
d'année 2023 le préfet honoraire Lalan
qui a mené une une mission de 3 mois
nous avons corédigé avec les élus la
police la douane l'agent armerie un
projet de de contrat territorial de
sécurité de prévention dans ce contrat
il y a un certain nombre d'Ax qui
répondent aux autres questions qui sont
posées sur le les les cellules de
ciblage il existe au sein de de la des
directions des douanes dans les brigades
d'aéroport des cellules de
ciblage il est bien évident que elles
sont en relation euh mais elles sont en
relation pas simplement
euh entre guyan Martini Guadeloupe mais
également avec nos collègues arrivrivée
de de de roiss ou
d'orli est important c'est au-delà du du
renseignement opérationnel qui peut être
transmis c'est aussi un renseignement
tactique que je vais qualifier comme ça
de pouvoir dire ben voilà les cellules
de ciblage ça reste à dimension humaine
on a à peu près entre 6 et agents donc
il y a des périodes où il y a un certain
nombre de vols c'est difficile de les
faire je dirais de manière complète par
contre utiler le temps de transport
entre guillemets sur les vols
transatlantiques ou même sur les les 2
heures entre la Guyane et la Martinique
permet dire bah voilà on a peut-être à
la cellule de départ pas beaucoup
travaillé ce vol donc il est plus
intéressant à contrôler à l'arrivée ou
on l'a très bien travaillé et on peut
mettre à l'arrivée notre notre activité
sur d'autres d'autres vols et donc ça
c'est quelque chose qui est vraiment en
train de se structurer de manière forte